vous savez pourquoi les gens sont
parfois en retard et pourquoi les autres
sont toujours à l'heure
les gens qui sont toujours à l'heure ils
savent qu'on les attendra et gens qui
imaginent présents pardon donc ils ont
peur et les gens qui sont toujours en
retard ils savent qu'on les attendent
donc vous savez que vous c'est un
rapport au monde j'ai une confiance
exactement dans l'Utah ou un parent
d'élèves a demandé et obtenu
l'interdiction de la Bible dans les
écoles primaires de l'État la Bible il y
a dénoncé les passages pornographiques
et indécent de l'Ancien Testament
[Musique]
dans le cadre d'une cérémonie religieuse
ils ont porté des chèvres des poulets
des légumes sur leur dos jusqu'au bord
du cratère pour jeter la nourriture en
guise d'offrande
Serval qui fait le rendez-vous
française
effectivement les compagnies aériennes
s'attendent à transporter
4,35 milliards de passagers dans le
monde cette année on est tout près du
record de 2019 avant la pandémie c'était
4,54 milliards de passagers ce sont les
chiffres de l'Association internationale
des compagnies aériennes le ministre des
comptes publics à trancher ce sera ni
ISF vers ni endettement la priorité
c'est celle du des endettements notre
pays je suis pas en train de vous dire
on va remplacer une dette par une autre
et donc l'endettement massif pour
financer la transition écologique
on peut pas se le permettre avec près de
3000 milliards d'euros de dettes les
commémorations maintenant du 6 juin 1944
c'était il y a 79 ans les Alliés
débarqués sur les plages de Normandie où
est présent vous le voyez pour
l'occasion le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron aux côtés de Léon
Gautier dernier survivant des 177 euros
français qui ont pris part à ce fameux
DJ ne redoutons pas l'avenir
car notre grande est vieille nation a
toujours su relever les défis du temps
et la légende de nos siècles nous y
oblige
le Mont-Saint-Michel est là pour
signifier que notre pays à toutes les
raisons d'espérer une nouvelle fois oui
j'ai une prise de conscience de faire
des efforts et je sais maintenant
comment appréhender la Sion ouais j'y
crois moyennement je pense qu'il y a un
réel travail de fond à faire et hélas un
coaching ne suffira pas et bien j'écoute
le président qui nous parle de
l'histoire et je regarde le présent et
je vois qu'il ne se bat pas pour
défendre ce qui fait l'identité
française
la viande rouge épinard
et deux trois choses aussi en plus
c'est une conception un peu figée
j'aimerais bien
alors David Douillet est venu pour les
30 ans du club de judo de Loriol il est
venu et il s'est échauffé il a fait
comme ça il a craqué son pantalon aux
fesses et il m'a donné
avec l'autographe
du cinéma avec une sortie de main qui
risque de faire du bruit un septième
épisode de lasuga Transformers sont de
retour pour sauver l'humanité vous le
voyez ils ont l'air bien déterminé
assez une fin de saison de Koh-Lanta
bon il a vécu regardez ça sa vécu
l'épreuve des poteaux et tout c'est vrai
et pas que regardez on vous l'offre un
pantalon porté par Dolly Boyard sur
Koh-Lanta c'est la charte à laquelle
sont soumises les hôtesses l'épilation
notamment et désormais obligatoire et ça
fait bien sûr bon dire les féministes
elle a un nom c'est le guide de
l'hôtesse parfaite ensemble des règles
très strictes imposées par la direction
du tournoi selon ce document pour les
hôtesses donc il est ainsi exigé un
maquillage léger mais toujours présent
et résistant aux intempéries l'employé
doit également avoir à disposition une
bombe de lacs pour les mèches rebelles
sans oublier d'avoir effectivement les
jambes et les aisselles épilées ces
consignes en tout cas tout de suite fait
réagir Sophie Binet la patronne de la
CGT a notamment dénoncé des pratiques
sexistes Sandrine Rousseau a parlé d'une
institution rétrograde PPDA lui a
déclaré j'arrive mais pour ce qui est
des hommes voilà c'est beaucoup plus
court il est principalement demandé de
tailler correctement la barbe et où de
se raser à blanc ils doivent par
ailleurs ces hommes porter un pantalon
large et les mêmes polos que les
hôtesses et là il y a une petite
variante à la différence que donc les
hommes doivent boutonner ce polo
jusqu'en haut alors qu'il est demandé
alors collègue féminine de laisser le
bouton du haut ouvert
quel tennisman français
surnomme-t-on Riton
[Musique]
si je peux me permettre techniquement on
a peut-être un petit souci avec le
buzzer parce que bah il a commencé à
beser la semaine dernière quand même le
domicile Rennais du joueur de tennis
Lucas Pouille a bien été cambriolé
confirme le procureur de la République
de Rennes cambriolage pendant que le
tennisman disputait le tournoi de
Roland-Garros à Paris d'après le JDD le
préjudice s'élèverait après de 600 000
euros Lucas pouic qui a été éliminé au
second tour
[Musique]
d'appréciations masculine j'apporte mon
petit témoignage
je trouve que les poils dépassent les
poils des femmes sont tellement tabou
qui a une force de frappe érotiquement
très qui est pas du tout négligeable et
ce que je trouve
même beaucoup mais mes partenaires
actuels que du coup je me conformais ce
qui était communément attendu de moi